Cowboys defense is no joke man and you
can vote for our next guest that's right
here on the Rich Eisen show for the Pro
Bowl I just I'm gonna give him a vote
right here his name is Byron Jones I
just gave him a Pro Bowl vote you can
with nfl.com slash Pro Bowl slash ballot
and do what I just did and I'm not just
doing that because he's kind enough to
call into the show after he and the rest
of the hot boys had a big signature win
on Thursday Night Football bots we've
been following Byron Jones ever since he
jumped out of a 2015 NFL Combine gym and
he came on the show were greatly
appreciative of that so I would say
friend of the program Byron Jones back
here now of the Dallas Cowboys Howry
Byron hey what's up rich thanks for
having me you bet what's gotten into
your defense Byron Jones guys are
stepping up making big plays see a lot
of young guys across the board our front
7 is something special at the corner
sometimes I just look inward and see
those guys it's going at it and it's
really special to see especially young
guys are stepping up and making huge
plays that's what that's what defense is
about it's just taking the ball the way
making your head to making your fit well
what are you seeing from that front
seven barn it's physicality guys and
have high energy guys who have high
effort when you're rushing the passer
when it comes down to who wants it more
who's going to fight for position and
more on our guys I know without a dollar
going to get there I know Jaylon Smith
and Layton band Ratt you're gonna run
sideline to sideline hit any running
back they're gonna come through the hole
so I feel comfortable with those guys on
the inside and then what DeMarcus
Lawrence was picking up it certainly
seemed like the rest of the team was
putting it down on Drew Brees and the
Saints what what did he have to say this
week to the media we heard it what was
he saying in the locker room I imagine
it's something similar and perhaps even
less safe for work yeah that's the
person he is you understood what this
game meant you know you have a team
that's coming here who was hot as the
Saints with so many big-name guys you
want to make a statement and he made a
statement before the game and I think he
made a statement during the game and I
think if you're gonna make a statement
like that again you gotta show up and
there's no question that he showed up
Byron Jones of the Dallas Cowboys
defense here in the Rich Eisen show what
happened after
Monday night game you haven't lost since
then with what switch got flipped what
conversation was had what was what was
going on that that has led to this Byron
I think I just think the guys the
coaches the staff and just kind of
understood at that point okay this is it
there's no more room for error you can't
contain a loose like this and expect to
go to playoffs and you work so hard
throughout the offseason no one people
real people don't really understand how
long the project is preparing to get
ready for a season and to be at that
point and understanding okay if we lose
again we're probably not going to the
playoffs and ultimately the Super Bowl
so just really the idea that their backs
against the wall you can't you can't
make any more errors but when as a team
you want to really get going in
november/december with where these games
really matter and I think we're doing a
good job at kind of understanding that
and taking that on board with us and I
not looking back man we're trying to win
some more games when you say a message
being sent from coaching staff how much
is does that come from your head coach
Jason Garrett a lot I think one thing
he's really good at is motivating the
players and you find different ways to
do it through not just sitting up there
and talking he finds videos speakers he
draws from a lot of different areas to
kind of motivate us and that's what he's
really been great at and when the
message gets across like there and you
can obviously see the way that we're
playing that's the sign of an effective
leader and that's what he's been doing
give me anymore give me an example of a
video or something that he's done to
motivate give me something so like we'll
watch the video of a Navy SEAL or even
Iraq you know explaining just the idea
of his philosophy and how he attacked
his life and he always sees himself
anytime he's in a big moment he
remembers back to where he didn't have
someone on the table or he didn't have
an income at all and where he was at his
rock bottom and he remembers that he
reminds himself how that felt at that
moment and then he then gets gratitude
from that and just goes out and
accomplishing whatever he has had in
mind to on that day so they just Allah
he brings in a coach care brings in a
lot of different ways to kind of
motivate us and get us gone and it's
really working so when you see did you
see the rock like Dwayne Giraud yeah
like yeah rock so he showed a video of
Dwayne Johnson talking about his life
experience and how
I can translate to success for you yeah
that's just one one of many things that
he's done to kind of motivate Allyson
you know as a leader you can't just say
the same thing over again and expect
people to get you have to find different
ways to do it and that's that's hard to
do and there's no question that he goes
to great lengths to do that for us and
that's valuable
I mean it's valuable to motivate an
invigorating group of guys and now we
had to talent in the locker room the
entire time which needed to put it
together and be consistent with it well
I've met coach Garrett many times off
the field he's an absurdly positive guy
I mean just a very positive upbeat
happy-go-lucky from what it seems but a
very intense guy Byron you know but you
do know that most uh fans of the NFL
think all he does is stand there in clap
for you guys right now I see it's funny
like I go on Instagram and I just I
don't look for particularly but you see
like little pictures of it just clapping
all the time and that's just he even
killed on the field yes I put up you
know you got to be even killed I think
that comes from his playing experience
as well he never sees never to find
everything low because he's played again
you can't be like that you can't be
fiery and down on yourself and you know
jumping for joy when when a touchdown
was made you got to be even killing the
sport but now he's one of those guys who
understands it because he played the
game before he understands what it takes
and and that's been a benefit to us as
players no question Byron Jones here
Cowboys cornerback and someone that you
should vote for for the Pro Bowl one of
the many Cowboys on that defense that
are Pro Bowl worthy right now right here
on the Rich Eisen show so let's uh you
know we're talking about speed in this
game team speed is important and how
fast Jalen's Smith can cover ground you
even said that yourself about Vander
rash as well but they're still the
fastest cowboy on the team right Byron
correct yeah you know I brag every now
and I remind the guys hey I'm the
fastest no question about that but it's
beautiful to see a guy who's you know
6-2 6-3
240 pounds running sideline to sideline
I think it looked cooler when they do it
no question so you're talking about
Vander rush right there I'm just about
both of them well
the manimals upside animals it's good
way to put it but you know but you were
able to guard the guy who says he can't
be guarded in Mike what were you able to
do with Michael Thomas last night do you
think I earn that few people in the
league are able to do well one I think
we got a bit of a good job getting press
on Jewry's and making it hard for him to
get the ball out and there were some
times I mean the guy is a really good
receiver and I felt that in the game
there are some times where he was
running free no question but RT Rd has
the beautiful beautiful part about
having a good defensive line we shoot
the soup I recently be running free but
you know a guy gets a hand on the ball
and we're okay so for me my technique I
just like the challenges to is at the
line of scrimmage I like to play tough
defense get my hands on them I don't
like to give grounds a line of scrimmage
and and I just like to fight contestant
and God look to hand you last night I
got a got a flag but uh that's bald man
you know I'm gonna make it hard as hard
as I can swear we see where to catch the
ball okay and then I guess where it all
comes to it Byron you're not allowed to
go one game at a time on me okay without
my question you're not allowed to do
that I understand that's the way it
works in the NFL I understand but this
is not my first rodeo asking this
question how far does this team go I
mean you've got your fanbase absurdly
excited with this four-game win streak
most watched Thursday Night Football
game ever with what you did to a red-hot
10 win team in a row 10 win in a row
team pardon me I mean how far can this
team go Byron I knew the sky's limit for
us when you look across the board you
see the type of players that we have on
the field and from the old guys to the
young guys quarterback receivers running
back defensive backs linebackers d-line
the sky's the limit and you're starting
to see it now where we're starting to
put together an entire team and put good
game a couple of good games and good
performances on top of good performances
and that's that's the key especially
during this time of the year where teams
are banged up teams kind of found their
identity we're really starting to go
into stride and start to build our mojo
right now so like I said minutes guys
limit we're trying to go even to the
plows to the Super Bowl there's no
question about that that's always a goal
coming into the season so the goal is to
keep doing it one by one
yes
you know it's amazing how because
everybody thinks that's all he does
literally that's all he does his clap
but obviously he does a ton more and you
guys are just coming out firing I mean
just firing it's really remarkable to
watch you what certainly you've done
over the last month I mean vanishes
howling right because he's no yay we
call him the wolf man yeah he's
definitely Harley guy's swag he's got it
confident so he's rolling that he's a
big dude in me right oh yeah I mean long
you can see the way he uses life on the
field he's punching out linemen and
tackling people it's it's really cool to
see Vance but he's on that young yes
definitely the most badass name Layton I
think of all time probably there's me a
while to get used to st. did Layton's a
badass there's no doubt about it
hey Byron how long did Garrett give you
off after that one ma'am chillin today I
was chillin tomorrow and I'm killin on
Sunday so yeah three four days on Wow
so he gave you a C or Tuesday no no
we're gonna have some on Monday no
question okay all righty meeting on
Monday and I hope I do a wreck with
Tuesday but like I said coach Garrett
gets it man he played the game you know
sometimes need a rest
late lay down watch Netflix what are you
watching I'm on narcos right now I'm
really fascinated by the trucks race for
whatever reason do it don't do any drugs
but it's fascinating to kind of see what
kind of goes on in different countries
okay so you're on narcos Mexico that's
the one that your honor
okay all right fine hey you take care of
yourself or really appreciate it let's
stay in touch
let's stay in touch as you go about your
business and your fourth season it's
amazing how long you've been at it out
of out of UConn so congrats on last
night's win and appreciate the time
thank you very much take care you got it
that's Byron Jones the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience